they are the faces of the children taken
before their lives had barely begun
faces that should haunt a country that
somehow allows these tragedies to happen
killed in their classroom at the robb
elementary school like sandy hook like
columbine like parkland taking its place
in a litany of unimaginable acts
so many like eliana garcia were taken so
many families grieving
found out of the tragedy we didn't find
out about her until late last night
around 11 30 that's when they confirmed
she was very happy and
very outgoing
loved to dance and sing and play sports
the rob elementary school is in a city
called uvalde around 80 miles west of
san antonio in texas first 18 year old
salvador ramos stopped by his
grandmother's house and shot her she was
airlifted to hospital
a truck believed to belong to the
suspect crashed outside of the school
building
sky news has confirmed the location of
the truck against a photo from news
agencies and videos shared online
ramos seen here with a long rifle and a
backpack was wearing body armor outside
the school
this video posted on facebook by
resident elsa louise appears to show the
suspect entering the elementary school
he then went into a classroom locked
himself in and opened fire evil
swept across
uvalde yesterday
anyone who
shoots his grandmother in the face
has to have evil in his heart
but it is
far more evil
for someone to
gun down
little kids
it is intolerable and it is unacceptable
for us to have in the state anybody who
would kill little kids in our schools
survivors were taken to the local civic
center where parents would either be
reunited with their children or have
their greatest fear confirmed
ramos had bought the rifles on his 18th
birthday social media images purporting
to be of him circulated after the
incident one features a gun another an
ammunition magazine
the white house flag was lowered to
mourn the lives taken a president and
his wife herself a teacher of course
wrestling with the horror and the
helplessness
when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
[Music]
uvalde in texas is now the scene of the
deadliest primary school shooting since
sandy hook almost 10 years ago many
thought that massacre of six and
seven-year-olds would change everything
it shames america
that it's changed nothing but once again
the calls for gun control come
there is a plague a plague upon this
nation
a plague of gun violence that has taken
over this country the problem in the
senate is simple
too many members on the other side of
the aisle are disconnected from the
suffering of the american people too
many members on that side care more
about the nra
than they do about families who grieve
victims of gun violence
the grief is unimaginable for the
families of uvalde but this is the 27th
school shooting this year in the united
states a country wondering if this
doesn't change anything
what will